okay alright enough of that okay alright
enough of that okay alright
okay hello everyone hi hi sorry sorry
didn't even blink sorry you can't answer
that question cuz you were dead yeah so
the whole thing with I don't know the
new cylinder map Oh Sunday's shadow he
actually wants to get on skype with me
but I don't have time for that I've got
a live stream they do so I don't know I
don't know what the deal is I don't know
what the deal is so so anyway we're
gonna get the SCP oh wait 7b started but
first I need to do some videos or some
updates on a fate on the Facebook you
see here I see the live stream has begun
we will be streaming scp-087 be until it
has been conquered conquered yeah that's
how you spell please stop by and enjoy
the screens of taro are the tear or
sorry
choked on my own terror there we go yep
not playing drunk minecraft no or not
there okay boost don'tdon't don don don
don don yes I can see your text
j-dog you cheating exploiting guy don't
think I don't know you were banned for a
reason j-dog their livestream
has begun upon by for scp-087 be
terrifying action I should take
terrifying SCP o h7 be action that would
be more correct and grammatically
correct okay
tweeted oh one second guys I can't read
your stuff I'm not looking at your stuff
hold on all dear lug nuts I'll get to
you in just a second I've got to take
care of some things where is it there it
is
sorry blah husha Busha ki scp-087 be
live livestream Biscay no that's not
right everybody please retweet the tweet
I just tweeted and please like the
Facebook pace post or share your
whatever okay do your own thing do what
you want to do don't don't let me tell
you what to do I'm just a youtuber
[Music]
lululu awesome - and bethke car - to fit
your manager and I released the YouTube
video SCP SCP wait 7b livestream slander
isn't on YouTube
shows what you know all right
yeah I'll I'll do I'll do Seventh Street
later I don't know what the deal is I
mean I don't think it's a problem on
Mayan considering I was able to run
every other slender map the guy release
but I don't know I don't know I
restarted in my computer I tried it
multiple times I tried it in different
ways
I tried compatibility modes I tried to
download that DLL that he tried but I
already had it I replaced it anyway I
did it again
I down well any wofford I don't know so
we're getting you behind me it's it's a
ceiling fan jack going too fast can't
keep up I can keep up ah yes thank you
it's a fan yes yes yes yes hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello hello hi
let's just have a let's have a let's
have a heart-to-heart one second one
second
am i normal mine or mille heart-to-heart
music
[Music]
so we just hit 15,000 subscribers Emily
you can go you can go away please you
can go away now you don't want to listen
to this
we just hit 15,000 subscribers so yeah
everybody celebrate right now because
it's also your accomplishment yeah we
got there we got to 15,000 yes now as
you all know this is going to is just a
small small small increment in my long
term goal of a hundred thousand
subscribers and my even longer-term goal
of a million subscribers at some point I
don't know what I'm gonna get there but
I just know that I'm gonna get a hundred
thousand subscribers hey this is there
this is their celebration time they can
celebrate a bit if moobot will keep them
in line but they can celebrate so yeah
but yeah so the but alright let me tell
you let me let me tell you something
that's honest and true being having the
principles that I do in terms of YouTube
I don't I don't beg for likes or
anything like that after each video I
don't beg for likes and comments and
favorites I don't do that because I feel
like you all would do that already if
you actually like the video I mean me
telling you that isn't gonna make you
like the video anymore the only thing
that matters to me is if you actually
enjoy the video and that's what's
important that's what's always been
important and that's what I think is
happening now and I'm never gonna start
asking you to like it or favorite it or
write a comment about oh no the music so
I'm not done talking that's so and so
yeah I I'm never gonna do that
eventually so a lot of other youtubers
have actually been talking to be like
you know they other youtubers are
finally starting to notice that I'm
growing pretty quickly and that's a good
thing its own right and they asked me
the they asked me about things that I'm
doing differently than them and I just
tell them that
I'm not really doing anything other
differently there is no secret there's
no anything you just gotta make exactly
what you want to do I'm speaking while
we're getting more people in here but
I'm and I try to tell other people that
people asked me because there are some
channels that are bigger than me but
don't grow as quickly as me and that
doesn't seem right to me because like if
they got that big then they should keep
that momentum going in you guys are the
secret I realized this it's not anything
I ever do moving back again it's not
anything that I ever do say anything
that I'll ever do it's all about the
people watching and that's what
youtubers have to remember and that's
what I'll always remember so thank you
guys it's you guys that are the driving
force behind the growth of this channel
and just because there I don't know I
don't know a couple hundred in here at
the moment but it's if you guys can't
get here and be with me
that's what's gonna drive us forward and
as we move into the future it's all
about you so I'm never gonna forget that
I said that when I had a thousand I said
that one I had like 500 I'll say that
when I have a hundred thousand it's
always gonna be about you so thank you
guys so much
I cannot say thank you enough so thank
you
now back to the creepiness hang on wait
no it's gotta be louder than that
[Music]
okay no no no no no no no no no no no
okay all right so I sent out the
messages I said my big spiel I said the
blah blah blah
talked a bunch which is what I'm really
good at so let's get what you all came
here for me to crap my pants oh I was
stalling that's what I was doing I was
stalling until we got the right thing
[Music]
I'll get that I got a running in window
mostly this I'm gonna hop out of it for
just just just a second
[Music]
no no get up there no get up oh you
gotta be kidding me
I did the screen region wrong dammit I
want to get that you you guys can see
that right the little stripe up at the
top I want to get rid of that and I
gotta change something since I'm playing
Wow whoops that's not right
oh gosh I'm stalling yes I am stalling
I'm stalling cuz look oh there's a
problem
I better go fix it right away I'm not
playing World of Warcraft I all fix that
now okay I gotta do hang on I gotta
Finnegan something cuz this thing's like
just evil and a half shut up go away oh
yeah alright so one second one second
let's see get ready for some mad
inception going on why hang out let's
see if this works yes I'm still stalling
no go hey go away ad oh never mind never
mind
whoa God okay alright so hang on I got
it I got it
there we go there's the inception I was
thinking of okay
alright now hopefully that'll be good
enough
powerfully I'll be good enough ah there
we go
hahaha
[Music]
[Laughter]
nothing bad happens for a while so I'm
good I'm good yep yeah yeah I know I
don't like it I don't like it I don't
like it
it's not it's not not better if you guys
are here it's just not it's not good
somehow it's just not not better
how about you turn down your volume okay
why am I still going forward why my Auto
going forward okay yeah I can't I can't
control the volume what for this game
individually I literally can't so turn
down your volume yep
I like how people is like all right it's
it's loud I can't I don't know what to
do about that well seriously guys I I
literally cannot do anything about oh
wait no I can but I'd have to restart so
let's just deal with this until I die
which should be any minute now I'm gonna
die real soon
[Music]
hey 10 yeah
do you wanna I don't wanna
and yeah guys when the monster pops up
if your volume is loud now just wait
till then so keep the volume kind of low
or else you're gonna not have happy fun
times was that 13 okay yes 14 left or
right left all right guys left or right
left or right left right right left
right left left right left left wrong
wrong wrong you're all wrong you were
wrong you were wrong I hate this game so
much oh you know chance left right left
right left right left right left right
right left right left left up up left
okay left
you were right it was not right it was
left yeah good good oh no nonono oh no
no nonono oh no no nonono 1717 damn it
damn it nothing happened
nothing happened damn it let's hurry
left right left
we'll go right go right yes I was right
or you said left or wrong it means they
love it wrong nineteen
who you knew didn't you plenty honey
turn around why I'll tie down I can't do
that I can't do upside down okay it's
not possible height is nothing happening
there's nothing happening 21 yeah I'll
go get drunk and forget about this
horrifying game
[Music]
ah don't worry guys and gals I got this
Tinker if she's saying that I'm not a
man I'm the man I'm a manly man I'm a
man I'm a man okay big choice guys left
right left right left or right left or
right I'm on level 25 to 525 right left
left right right let it certainly hat
left left left
I saw more less than right
[Music]
get it okay hey I know I'm good do it
again
I'm doing it again I'm gonna do it again
I cranked down the volume a bit here we
go again
[Music]
I've made it oh no you're not always
supposed to go left uh okay okay I've
made it as far as level 35 native as far
as level 35
[Music]
you're stupids Hey look one of my mods
put J Doug 21 in timeout he's deserves
it thank you yes yes yes what what what
is this
we've never seen this before what not
right no who's he
we're gonna Wow what is this this is all
wrong everything is wrong it's it
doesn't make sense oh okay okay
I don't know what that was all time I
played this a couple times and I've
never seen it before never seen that
before I've never ever seen that before
[Music]
okay arent you swedish i could speak
swedish if you like dude you on floor
[ __ ] good job bjork bjork bjork bjork
yep locked okay i'm gonna i'm gonna grow
a pair and I'm not afraid I'm not scared
I am a man I'm a man and I will
persevere I can do that too I can do
that too
I'm so mad I'm so manly I built my house
at a trees that I punched down with my
fists I'm what is that
I saw something y'all saw something I
[Music]
know I'm not playing I know it's the
only option you douche girl I'm so manly
that I don't even know left
[Music]
yep all right I'm so manly I get those
puzzles on the first try
sorry 15 15 all right so far so
uneventful 16
okay okay okay okay okay I got it I got
it I got it I got it shut up
will yes yes I will Oh God why 17
I hate 17
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right all right I was one of them
holes in the wall I don't I still don't
know what I'm supposed to do about those
holes in the wall 20 yeah 20 oh I think
what happens in those holes in the walls
like the Hulk pops out of nowhere and
just sticks his dick in my eye
I'm pretty sure that's how it works I'm
pretty sure what game is this
it's SC p o8 7b there was no
[Music]
I just know I just know something's
gonna pop right in my eye and rip my
face off yeah yeah well what thoughts
awesome mother
yeah well see something did anybody else
see that or was I just going crazy there
I think I was going crazy
[Music]
2424 oh okay here we go
24 not so bad not so bad
25 and a choice right
[Music]
turn it up again again again okay all
right I get this oh man oh oh god I'll
get in a second one second one second
one second oh man oh god I almost
shattered my new keyboard it's crappy I
yesterday during drunk minecraft I broke
my keyboard you'll see how in the
episode tomorrow which is a very special
episode that I'm coming out with but I
had to replace it with this crappy $10
POS keyboard and it's got orange on it
I was shattered in half at that last one
oh all right so here we go we're going
again whoo boy ah shut up about seven
three I can't get to work all right
anyway so yeah I wanted to get a better
keyboard but I can't afford it at the
moment so I gotta stick with a POS here
we go here we go no that's wrong
wait hang on I got this
err ah tits all right okay yeah hang on
one sec I got this what the hell is that
symbol anyway I don't know what that is
all about anyone know that that is aa
monkey oh here we go
like a mouse okay I'm gonna get through
the first 15 floors like a boss cuz I
know that nothing bad happens I know
nothing bad happens to like 17 and
beyond so [ __ ] you noise always that you
think you're bad I think I'm so much
worse you don't even know you don't even
know you don't even know you don't even
know okay I'm gonna go I'm not gonna
it's all about luck with those choice
puzzles I mean I tried going back once I
made the wrong choice the first time but
you know you know you you you you you
you you don't even know you don't even
know you don't even know you don't even
know you don't even know shut up shut up
bricks shut up
just stop hmm
what was that what was that yes oh no
not this again
I don't know what this is all about but
do not know what this is all if it it's
just like it's just like nothing no no I
don't know keep going eleven shut up
ha yeah this one's gone perfectly well
why don't you jinx me like that why
don't you darkness this is a special
request as per someone who donated quite
a bit of money there one request was
that I play a CPE Oh eight seven beyond
livestreamer left left okay
Persian ex it's all on you you're wrong
Persian X is wrong person X was wrong
rah
oh I don't want to do an accent what
accent would I do accent 115 who had
money on 15 who had money on 15 you like
me to do Bain really now Wow
you think the darkness is your ally you
merely control the darkness I was thrown
into it killed by it
Oh left I'm the best
uh-oh
people saying right or wrong behind a
who's behind a behind a good behind 18
we passed right by 17 okay don't say
that T real don't say that
19 19 20 20 20 20 good old 20 i am i am
recording this so it will be it will be
going up on youtube will be going up
turn around why okay hey hey well let's
see 22 not dead yet not dead yet
are you behind me are you behind me I'll
see ya douche douche
ya got here to get out here okay here
get out here yeah
don't either a either 23 23 23 23 that's
good I know I scare him I did what my
face is so ugly that it just scares
people off Hulk Hulk Hulk BAM right now
okay all right
yes a lot of people came to watch me
scream like a little girl that's that's
phenomenal I'm so happy about that my
goodness I'm doing good
I'm doing real good real real real real
real good 27 and here comes the big the
big big big big kiss her right right I
feel I feel right feeling it I'm never
gonna be good gonna do bad you did again
hey go get others okay you get ha go I
don't even care
oh I don't even know I don't even know I
don't even know I don't know got it shut
up I tell you
ah there you go
okay all right one more time one more
time one more time one more time more
time
JV what does that mean what does it mean
oh dude what does it mean okay okay well
the glasses are more your size ran out
of contacts I have disposable daily
contents so you think you know but you
don't you think you like it but you
don't you think I'm good at this game
but I'm not high like a boss
lack a mouse like a mouse like a mouse
like a bouncy house well I thank you I
am I am happy that I can entertain you
with the sultry baritone that is my
voice for I will carry on I promised I
promise the one the person who donate
who is unfortunately I don't think she's
that she's here right now I don't think
that the requester of this is here at
the moment which is a shame but
hopefully she'll be able to see it oh
yes Hey hi ha are you enjoying it so far
are you enjoying it so far the red death
Reaper hope you are OPI do ice acting
yep I just got Alden yes thank you red
death for making me do this and donating
such a considerable amount so thank you
for that boy got your face I will smash
you in the I'll smash you with a bottle
in the neck and then stab you with that
bottle in the neck I don't even know if
you have a neck I don't even know if you
have a body all I see you like a face
yes red death is awesome thank you so
much all right all right all right all
right all right all right person I don't
know if I can win I don't know if I ever
can oh man I'm sweating my hands are all
coated in sweat it's getting real hot in
this room I should have voiced Master
Chief I think that was a bit before my I
was mature in my voice
okay that's good that's good I'm always
happy to inspire I hope I can continue
to inspire as I pay my pants everyone
can be a good app in my past you can be
a youtuber 200 did you used to sound
like a girl I don't think so I don't
think I ever had that high voice I think
I I think it was just like once I hit
puberty normal and then cubed Ian whoa
like way way down for some strange
reason I looking did anybody see
anything did anybody see anything
did anybody did you guys say something
did you see I'm just having to look down
at that one moment it saw a person a
person how long have I been making
videos since April 5th April 5th is when
I started officially of this year April
5th you'd like to see a little kid with
my voice yeah there's some little
three-year-old hey guys how's it going
you just want a brand new car come on
down and get your prize today you're
tuned in in 92.5 the Fox oh boy
who's level 17 zone 17
those days no 17 okay do you know Ken
how did you get so many viewers I talked
about this in the beginning before I
study it's it's uh it's basically once
you get started you could only do so
much yourself just try to make the best
videos you're can and connect with your
audience let them see you who had your
weakest just I don't know I can't answer
that question right now I'm a little
preoccupied and for those of you who
didn't know I had good I hit two
thousand subs and had to restart because
my old had sense account got banned
before I could get partnered so that's
another long story long 20 hi yeah yeah
20 I love 20 20 is the best alright
alright
oh I hate him so much I hate him I hate
him I hate I never know what he's behind
me I always have to stand there cuz I
can't run backwards cuz he might be
behind me and if I run backwards he's
gonna be good oh okay I never know I
have to stand completely still until I
see him and then that's it and then I
bet I got very good I can move up
because people want to see me losing
this because people want to see me die
basically cuz that's what I'm Hey
I scream like a little girl the most I
swear I never had a higher pitched voice
than in this game 24 it's this funky one
that's okay that's okay
cuz there's a shortcut right to the
stairs right there 25 25 the big two
five darkness lightness still dark the
big 25 going down to 26 all right we can
do this guy's
we can do this 26
don't do that
god damn guys he's got huh man oh that
freaking face of that freakin uh stop
[Music]
27:28
please please no no no okay good - I
thought it was a splitting puzzle I
can't do an inhale screen okay oh okay I
can do it I can do it
twenty-nine
[Music]
I could've sworn that was going to be it
I coulda sworn that's where the Hulk was
just come pop out and bam
dick right in the eye I Cooter's for now
I was gonna be hit by 30 yeah yeah 40
oh hell damn Oh God 31
[Music]
yeah oh man oh man all right still
pushing on going down 32 what have you
got for me there buddy what have you got
come on come on I'm ready for you buddy
for you 33 Wow I can roar 234 oh no oh
no oh no we gotta be right guys we gotta
be correct here we gotta be correct
left or right right left left right left
left right right left left right you
suck so much people yeah all right
lizard of guilt this is all on lizard of
guilt if I die it's lizard of guilt
vault
[Music]
yeah Oh God
thank you lizard of guilt Oh in so many
ways this is so terrible 35 we have
officially officially gone farther than
we've ever gone down her gradual frickin
lations okay gradually yes yes
[Music]
what do i do wait he said something
don't look at me okay one of my mods
needs to tell me what one my mom needs
tell me what to do here
don't he's saying don't look at him look
at the floor as I go forward okay okay
[Music]
looking at the ground looking at the
ground
[Music]
ground out looking at ground
oh I blame lizard
I blame lizard oh I blame lizard oh oh
god oh god again the red death Reaper do
I have to do it again
should I do it again the red death
Reaper should I do it again
oh all right I'm gonna do it again I'm
gonna do it again
all right I'm gonna do it again here we
go one more time one what does that mean
[Music]
okay here we go one level two levels all
right you have to look at the monster
all the time he's walking in here ha ha
all right the Red Death you got it
I can do this I can do this
okay so when that guy comes out I think
the conclusion is I have to look at him
cuz he was coming towards me I saw like
just from the the corner of my I saw him
like moving towards me so I have to look
at him when that happens okay all right
okay all right I'll smile
[Music]
and
shut up like a boss not stopping not
stopping look at the corner in maintains
Richter what I don't know what you're
talking about
oh wait no I do yeah and that oh okay I
know we're talking about I know I know I
learned that lesson I learned that
lesson I'll get that
look at that there's random floors it's
random it's completely random and sorry
it's hard to pay attention to chat and
play the game because I have to focus on
what I'm doing right now so it's hard to
look at that was the fakie one that was
the nut that was the not murderous not
kill you 1:16 see um I will get I will
get a peel box set up pretty soon 17
here we go okay all right I will get a
peel box set up pretty soon here so if
you guys want to send me stuff and you
want to correspond with me okay left
like a boss like Burroughs I will yes I
will get a peel box pretty soon it's
just some there's a lot of things that I
need to get right now that I just don't
have the money for I mean I am partnered
on You Tube but it pays me on a delay so
like don't worry guys it it just takes
time right now I'm a poor student with
lots of medical bills and my keyboard
just broke okay anyway oh oh
railing I'll get it I'll get it I'll get
it if any of you have a copy of a PC
version of Silent Hill 2 and want to
want me to play it because I've been
looking for that and the only copies
I've found our uber expensive um I I
could I need to finagle with moobot a
bit so but also yeah I think I think
I'll have to figure that out
21 let's all get hammered see yeah I
know most people have Silent Hill 2 for
the PlayStation but I'm trying to
ah girl okay I'm pretty good at that
part I'm pretty good that I'm pretty
good at that
what happened last time I couldn't see
there was there's a guy I was supposed
to look at him and he was telling me not
to look at me I will die soon
shut up snipe I'm on him I'm gonna make
it I'm on a racket I'm on a wreck I'm
gonna get it I'm gonna get it I'm gonna
get it I'm gonna get it all right this
is the 125 oh right yeah like a boss
like a mouse like a mouse like a mouse
actually you know when you go right the
corners pretty close there so maybe if
you go just a little bit to the right
and if you don't see it like back out
and go left
okay nice dubstep when did i do dubstep
see III would like to get a copy of
Silent Hill 2 for the PC I just haven't
been able to this is hard to get ahold
of huh my visions go glory what's there
what's there something there something
there Oh something is there something is
there guys what why do i do what do i do
is he's just gonna stick a dick in my
eye is it gonna just keep going dick in
the face ignore the window just run by
okay don't look through the hole okay I
almost looked in that hole I almost
looked in the hole ha ha ha
I almost like No okay so you don't look
at the hole you look at the guy that
says don't look at me you look in the
corner when you get a monster in the
corner okay I see
[Music]
is it another guy another one don't look
don't look don't look don't look don't
look don't look
yeah hahahaha I got your number now 31
[Music]
okay like a boughs like
see here 33 okay all right okay okay
okay okay doing good doing good doing
good doing good I got this I got this
uh-huh it's you I know I'm looking at
you I'm [ __ ] looking at you will you
do now
we're gonna do now where are you is that
you
I figured I see you I see you I see you
your little red I see her you [ __ ] I
stop what now huh yeah oh alright
alright alright oh yeah oh yeah oh oh
yeah Oh No is he still there left I'm
gonna do my peekaboo on the right and
see if I can see something okay I can't
really I don't think it's there I'm
gonna go left come on
oh don't be like this go right go right
go right right lizard or Gilda saying
right so I don't think this is correct I
do not think this is correct
it's not correct this was not correct I
knew it I knew he wasn't that correct
I'm so lucky that a monster did not
spawn there I knew I knew it it's very
close if you just peek in you guys you
guys
damn it lizard damn it lizard damn it
lizard lizard damn it come on damn it
lizard get you [ __ ] gather lizard
37 Oh take two really really is this how
we're gonna play it all right if I can't
see it
it might be a corner there I can't tell
is that a corner or what is that a
corner I can't tell I can't tell I don't
think it's here
I don't think he's here I think it's
left I don't think it's there
Oh God
I don't know I don't know Oh God yes
yeah yes oh god oh god oh man oh we are
so ha ha don't give me another frickin
puzzle pass path puzzle
[Music]
don't give me another one of those
please
38 ok is this another breather don't
look not looking you dick get out of
here get your [ __ ] out of here get at
you oh yeah okay I heard it yeah I got
it I got it
39 another one more breath or is it okay
breath is over breath over breath over
breath over breath over I got this honey
boo boo I got honey boo boo honey boo
boo got lived it down okay hole in the
wall not looking anyway screw you
five guys is not terrible Oh five guys
it is not Tara five guys has the best
burger I've ever tasted
ever it's delicious I need some super
juice but super juice a lot of people Oh
not today you douche not today not today
what was that breathing I'm just
preemptively looking down one right here
any of any sort of breathing 43 okay
come on
oh come on oh come on 44 Oh No
ah fudge all right let me do with a peek
let me deal with the peak peak peak peak
peak always at a corner I'm not very far
in so come on I'm not seeing it I think
left not seeing it it might be it's
crazy it might be but Oh God and I'm
gonna just try to get a little closer
here okay I'm not seeing the corner to
wrap around I'm gonna go left I can't
take risked I know I can't take risks
that's why I'm trying to check here we
go come on
oh don't [ __ ] me
yes yours yes yes yes yes yes yes oh
shut up you don't see a coroner super-k
I'm watching I'm watching it I'd if I
don't see a coroner when I'm that far in
I'm not going down that way yeah man the
purpose of this game I don't know scare
the crap out of you cuz that's what it's
doing 45 45 can't see you can't see you
there we go alright 45 46 come on come
on yeah no where are you you behind me
[Music]
god dammit I knew he was I was trying to
creep forward god dammit oh man oh man
huh fudge fudge
fudge okay I don't know I got a it's
this this whole stream is sponsored by
the Red Death she donated quite a lot of
money to give me the place so if she
wants me to do it again I will do it
again because I did not get the deal the
deal was to get to level 50
[Laughter]
[Music]
well it's the beating the game is
getting to like a certain point where
good stuff
whenever I should have known that
whenever that happened I got to move
forward enough until I see the guy and
then I got to get back that's what my
problem was that's why that's what my
problem was that's why it's that's why I
didn't make it that time uh Red Death
said I could do something else but I
want to beat this thing I wanna I want
to beat this thing I want to beat it
really badly I want to beat it now
I'm I'm getting to the point where like
the scares aren't like killing me so
like I'm getting to the point where I
just want to beat it now you know I want
to beat it I wanna beat this [ __ ] I went
up I want to win I want to win I want I
want to beat this mother fudger I want
to smash it in its face and I thought
you just try it I'm gonna win I'm gonna
win I got this I know grabbed by the
balls grabbed it bah bah bah
huh yeah now I'm a little better I know
how to beat every single one of these
monsters I know how to be them so if I
can beat them I even kind of know how to
beat them the the double choice a peek
in on the right side it's not there I go
the other way okay I'm going to to enact
set the entire time I'm going to beat
this thing in too thick no I'm not gonna
keep that up bro Kittanning forbid you
didn't blow kicking forward you didn't
yes I know my accent is so sick yeah my
accent is the best yar
shut up sure tip I am going to blow this
out of the way do you shave space I'm
not gonna be beaten by the silly stupid
one the stupid one I can't believe this
stupid one pun that got stupid one got
me the one that I can beat every single
time that's the stupid one so whenever I
see that I'm just gonna scoot forward
until I see him if I don't then I just
go forward
[Music]
doing good doing good run 11 we're me
I'm gonna just keep pushing forward as
fast as I can to get back to where I was
once I hit like 30 and 40 that's when I
start to be cautious I'm gonna give this
I'm gonna dive that's pretty much
guaranteed but I've want to see the end
of this I really really do like I've
been I've invested enough time in this
that I think I deserve to see the ending
what's my favorite pickup line hey baby
did you fall from heaven did it hurt
when you fell from heaven cuz cuz your
face is kind of messed up yeah that's my
favorite pickup line
[Music]
yes it's oh it's super effective oh gosh
Oh guys you you don't even know how
effective it is the girls just go oh my
goodness oh that's a gut cow they go
alright oh no these wait what what the
hell did I get turned around the hell
just happened my mouth seems to be
freaking out
[Music]
the hell am i okay here we go yeah back
on track 17
all right bring it on buddy I saw that
dick I saw that yes yes oh yes delfield
Gabe dealt feeling L feel I bet the P is
silent
l feel
yes yes Brazilian accent I don't think I
could do a Brazilian accent what up I'll
see you again it's just my mouse foot me
right around I'm playing World of
Warcraft I don't think I am I'm pretty
sure this is not where the Warcraft oh
yeah I cannot do a boot to Canadian
accent E I can do - yeah yeah let's go
and drink some bagged milk kaput now
Italy's at the time I'm so sorry for
interrupting you e where are you Ronnie
in front of me haha got you I see you I
see you and your gun that's what I
thought that's what I thought that's
what I thought I can't I don't think I
can I think Canadians do sounds like
that Abu Tejada who the hooptie ha da
Dada Hootie Hootie oh hey - Huey as I
just lose all of my Canadian viewers yes
yes
ah here we go watts patented sneak back
sneak technique I can get to about here
do I see a corner I do not I back out go
this way and what do you know it I am
correct
I am very correct off du Lieber I can't
do a German it all right like a bounce
[Music]
I need to get seven-speed to work I was
having some trouble
finagling it and 28 doing good doing
good more than halfway to my goal where
where see behind me he's behind me
anything he's a dick he's a dick
they don't always pop up there what is
he doing Oh what
[Music]
nope not going to happen not going to be
happening today
it says I'm playing miss what it says
I'm playing World of Warcraft again
that's stupid it said I was playing
World of Warcraft before and I switched
it is it back now oh oh you might not
have refreshed I switched it probably
didn't refresh it never changed why I'm
not believe it or not this is not World
of Warcraft Mists of Pandaria I mean
there were a lot of changes in the
recent expansion this is not I don't
know I changed it I did and I oh if I
make it through this all changed again
well I mean what time I'll play it this
in fact is the new Wow yeah they wanted
to take in a more horror aspect of it
the monsters are actually other players
is pvp arena
[Music]
okay apparently some people have SCP on
it some people do not so I don't know
what the deal is what floor are we on I
think we're about hit 30s if we know we
pass 30s but at 35 35
what is that what is that ah that was
nothing right there was nothing okay
I don't need to worry about that I'm
looking at your dick oh that oh wait
where are you I see you I see you I see
I got my eyeball on you
oh what's that yeah how about because
you're so ugly
I just tried to boost up your
self-esteem of it by looking at you is
that a breather breather ah oh god I
thought that was gonna kill me huh yeah
damn it oh man I really thought that was
gonna kill me I'm so scared just for the
fact that I works hard to get down here
and I didn't wanted you to kill me again
[Music]
all right yeah if you guys are new my
name is markiplier I run the YouTube
channel markipliergame the wizard of the
guild just link there I do other horror
Let's Plays I even do more of this back
when I was first playing it I was okay
that's a that's a breather
I hear okay 40 we're at 40 we're at 40
guys is where [ __ ] gets real this this
is where [ __ ] gets real I have a perfect
body why thank you I need to work out it
flipped me around again I'm trying to
get back in shape but I will soon
I know I can do it 42 42 42 okay 42
sometimes I got I got I gotta watch out
for those guys that pop up behind me man
I gotta watch out 43 here we go
I saw that you go away oh god I hate
that so much do a potato accent what
thank you I try I try to have a good
voice something you're born with
no guy in the corner here all right can
I do an Indian accent no I'm really not
good with accents guys I'm not even good
with impressions I can only do very few
Oh Russian like I'm trying to focus here
guys I'm trying to focus on 45 I'm
trying to focus
well I mean if you could add sex with a
voice why would you have want to just
have sex with a voice you could have sex
with someone who has my voice I guess me
47 done 48 thought I heard a breather
I'm gonna look down anyway just in case
oh holy crap guys holy crap guys for
what yeah what good don't even know yeah
what do yeah I'm gonna assume that I
made it to past 50 I don't know I am so
confused my hand let me look at the next
one ah 50 all right let's get going
let's see how far we can go now I'm in
trouble
Oh just 51 shut up
can't beat me oh god yeah yes yes you
proud of me the Red Death proud of me
proud of me
ahh breather I knew it
oh yeah that's right baby
I did that for you the Red Death out
there 53
I hear you breathing ah what okay come
on come off before 54 doing good oh god
damn it oh man
[Music]
55 that's another breathing oh but how
do I get keep king turn around like that
now looking at you
that's right going that's right get out
of here
56 another reading whoa see see did you
see that it did it it did that you see
doesn't sound good
that sounds pretty bad what is in the
window I'm the Hulk who wants to stick a
dick in your eye
we've decided this already 57 shut up I
will go down if I want to go down John
josh NOS ha ha ha ha I beat your record
ok
oh did it again it did it again it
flip-flopped me it does that oh man it
just changes things
trying to get me to go backwards 59 what
is this this looks weird
what uh whoa what the hell where the
hell am I
what did what is going on things have
changed that was completely different
from anything I've seen
what what the hell is going on here
I'm like Lee what done they just what
okay it's like a maze now it suddenly
turned into a maze like thing I have a
bad feeling it's gonna take me the wrong
direction and just kill me ah okay down
again what the hell was that
stop
what what what whoa what did that's a
sign yeah fu - what
oh my ha what you behind me what's going
on
oh yeah what what oh no what oh oh I'm
going I'm going for it I'm going the
distance I'm going oh my god oh no oh no
oh no I'm going the distance he's going
for speed
he's jeez all alone alone at a time of
need yes god damn okay
oh man I never thought I'd ever ever
ever ever ever get this far I don't know
64 hot damn
I wasn't like I was gonna stop man oh
man 65 55
Oh a 65 wait what did I just get flipped
yeah I got flipped again this like thing
is trying to get me to go in circles
here that'd be very bad if I was being
chased like I was 66 66 ain't gonna stop
game you can't make me you can't beat me
well you probably can but not right now
one roll 67 got a breather all right
I'm a girl get away from door sorry caps
shut up don't know what you are is I'm
gonna find you why would the SCP send
someone down here well I know they send
like murderers to do all their testing
for them people in prison but still it's
pretty cruel game name please really oh
yeah I guess you can't see the game name
sorry some issues with the game name
going up I wish oh man oh man well we
missed 70 but yeah 70
yeah boss I'm a mouse happy birthday
Eddie happy birthday
holy hell 72
[Music]
oh man I'm getting so tense guys my hand
is like sweating balls and ha ha ha I
can't believe it
I can't believe it oh man oh man oh man
oh man oh man 74 oh don't tell me it's a
splinter
it's a splinter ok gonna creep gonna
crepe I'll see you a corner that's the
corner that is it you can creep you can
creep creeping works the corner is very
distinct it's very distinct easy to spot
got like a recipe to beat this game 75
breather looking down go a breathing got
it
nailed it another breather I can deal
with it Oh Molly what you in front of me
you in front of me you douche yurina no
you're not oh you're behind me come on
bring it bring it bring it bring it
bring it bring it bring it bring yes
that's right that's right
just right 77 77 okay do the creep do
the creep ah it's at the corner that
looks like the corner that's the corner
okay who the creep ah
[Music]
all right
holy crap I am I am [ __ ] nailing this
to the wall [ __ ] you breathing got it
damn we're almost at 80 we're almost 80
another breather Oh what do we got in
front of me in front of me yurina again
they're only doing the backwards now
they're only doing the ones behind me
now come on bring it bring it dick get
out of here get out of here get out of
here 80 yes
80 80 80 guys 80 guys 80 80 holy crap
holy crap
81 well it flipped me [ __ ] it keeps
flipping me gravy get out here nailed it
oh man I'm so home an 82 shut up Bella
breather I can deal with it okay happy
birthday an EXO happy birthday up don't
flip me can't believe me cannot flip me
I'm in it to win it in it get this I'm
gonna get this time go go home eat a
bagel up in front of me yeah
oh yeah
alright still rocking it mommy
you know for a game that's only 2 point
4 megabytes I've said it before but god
damn there's a lot of stuff coming dude
a creep due to creep it's at the corner
looks like the corner corner got it
nailed it
Oh like a boss like a boughs oh don't
turn me around you cannot can't do that
to me
yeah it's ok guys thanks ha man we're
gonna win this
Oh God 86 now look at 8686 I know it's
impossible to eat chocolate I walk in
front of me
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa yes
that guy was close so I don't know I I
was like super slow going backwards
there 88 88 88 88 88
how far can this game go I don't know I
don't think anyone really knows it's
randomized and here we come up on 90
coming up
90 yeah all this again due to creep it's
at the corner that corner it's like a
corner or again rights all around rights
all up in it yo oh yes oh yes is this 90
91 Oh another one I ain't no big deal
for me creep doesn't look like a corner
that is not a corner that is not the
corner Booya and blood ow just like that
[Music]
Oh God we're getting close to a hundred
guys we're we're getting close to 100 oh
[Music]
hello here we go 92 I don't know why it
suddenly jumped to 122 and then stopped
and I don't know yeah I'm getting
nervous too guys 93 I've been nervous
since like 40
I bet on like the edge of my seat the
entire time like I'd like drowning in
smiles or drowning a sweat right now 94
now I'm looking at you now looking at
you no dick in my eye
get out of here 95 nope that was another
breathing gimme 96 this is another one
another breathing
[Music]
gotta let that sweat off my hands 97 97
oh nope not gonna flip me oh boy
happy birthday 98 that's a breathing get
the F out of here breathing oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god 99 whoa me
again yeah yeah oh yes okay and we keep
going there's another breathing get out
of here
douche douche monster
101 101 101 okay cool okay
oh I will play seventh Street slender
7th Street after this but that'll be on
a let's play so it won't be
live-streamed yeah here breathing too
many breathing's BRE these are easy to
be give me so give me a challenge 103
who's that how do you donate oh well
thank you if you want to donate to me
there's a little widget down in the
description below I mean you can click
on the chip in it's a chip in which the
same things they use for child's play go
straight to me so thank you guys for
wanting to donate to me that really
helpful get me a new keyboard there is
an end I know there is an end
it's got boring I'm sorry I'm boring I'm
not boring you
[Music]
I know I know I know I know
yep yeah thank you yeah I do I really do
appreciate a donator is the person that
made me made me play this got me to go
past 50 and beyond
so that was the Red Death Reaper so
thank you so much red death Reaper you
are the best
what was that
108 up by me oh god damn oh he was right
up in my face oh man holy crap
109 I was thinking it was another one
behind me because I was creeping forward
like that oh man
110 oh yeah how much did the red death
Reaper donate all breathing look down um
she donated a hundred and forty dollars
and then I think she donated more so she
donated a lot I hope I owe her like way
more than just this game I owe her a lot
I hold her I owe her like sexual favors
I owe her so much like seriously it is
crate $233 holy crap yeah thank you so
much the Red Death Weaver like hey you
you don't know how much that helped so
thank you so well by me in front of me
oh you're behind me hi
bye so I didn't mean to instigate the
crowd by saying that or breathing
oh I just you know that's how it goes I
say I say the word sex and everyone goes
huh what what take oh no oh it's wrong
again
[Laughter]
well smoosh popper if you donated four
hundred I would pretty much be in debt
to you for a lot like one big favor
doesn't matter what it is you can
basically ask anything yep we are in it
to win it you guys this this is going
crazy there's a sect huh whoa
116 we are at 116 if you're just joining
us we are going down ah shut up breathe
II like once you get once you play it
enough you start to develop a strategy
[Music]
banana what oh well oh oh it's this
again
oh it's just weird like f-duct maze
thing they got going on I'm not exactly
sure what the deal is with this I don't
know if a monster like chases me through
this maze but let's see if it's the same
thing cuz I went left left right to get
through to get out of it before and I
think it's gonna let me out left left
right that is the pattern for that BAM
150 yen well that's not as much but ah
you can donate with your heart that's
beautiful
oh that's like the sweetest thing I've
ever heard
kind of cheers me up now that that I've
been playing this for so long 119 119
yes yes
well don't donate your heart don't don't
don't don't do that don't work just
please don't donate your heart 120 I'm
almost at the level that I saw on the
door before I wonder if that's something
you think it said 122 before because
that's the end I'm almost at 122 I'm
almost at the place I used to be okay do
the green ah
doodle weep oh that's a corner
I'm almost I wonder what to do oh my god
you think you think that might be it
guys if you donate please send me an
email at markiplier gmail can one of my
moderators please link my email
markiplier gmail.com please send me an
email and confirm and say that you did
and I'll get in contact with you I
really do appreciate 1:22 oh this again
left oh maybe this is gonna be something
oh oh I know this is just the same
puzzle but I'm thinking like this puzzle
is kind of special so maybe at the end
of it
1:22 is a big number come on come on
come on come on come on come on oh damn
it down again 123 ok
um guys say a number that I should stop
at or should I just keep going until I
hit an end or do you want do you want me
to keep going keep going forever until I
could be done never stop okay I was just
wondering I was wondering I was just
wondering okay whoa whoa whoa chat what
are you doing chat stop 125
[Music]
artists don't stop believin hold on to
the feelin feel it beep oh in front of
me find me Oh areas hi hi hey how you
doing
stop when you get to $500 I can't see
how much I can't get out of the game
right now so I don't even know if people
are donating to be right now if you are
thank you so much it really is
appreciated like you guys are the best
yes that's 128 I'll breathing OH
[Music]
breathing and a guy what where what I
missed it I was not looking up 129 plate
oh okay 130 130 guys whoa you behind me
I think he's behind me no please not
slips out tape jab step down exactly now
me I think you got it
[Music]
they're coming for frequently now it's
like really getting up on it
131 guys 131 I will play Resident Evil 6
someone donated money just selected by
that and I will 132 132
I do I can't feel it I'm not I don't
think I'm stopping at a certain point
I'm just stopping it we in front of me
behind me info
four hundred and forty dollars thank you
guys so much that's incredible
yeah please send me emails if you do
donate please do I'm I mean it's
phenomenal you guys are really helping
me out I do need a new keyboard I need a
new Mouse eventually but you guys are
really helping me out okay so thank you
guys so much and also remember I do do
charity streams I do charity streams so
if you don't want to donate now that's
fine donate to the charity whenever I do
them that that is more important than
donating to me
well absolutely if you want to go past
five hundred I'm not gonna stop you it
would not the thing is not gonna stop
just because it hits five hundred you
can go over a goal I just said five
hundred cuz I didn't want to say hey
give me a couple thousand dollars yes
1:37 alright 721 viewers Wow
thank you guys so much the donation is
just to keep me alive whoa hey hey whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
goddamn buddy seriously get a little too
close there I'm on twitch I have not
been partnered just yet on twitch
1:39 another brie V keyboard do I want
well if I had a dream I would have the
g19 but I think that's a bit too much
money for not enough keyboard I mean the
Mac I to g15 because I played World of
Warcraft and I needed those macros and
but you know now I don't you know not so
much whoa whoa that's different this is
different it's different it's different
why is that there hello guys hey hey I
did this home and change
wait whoa something different and look
at well oh no did I get turned around
[ __ ] did I just get turned around ah
nevermind nevermind I'm an idiot I'm an
idiot I'm an idiot
1:41 breathing
I got flipped and I didn't even notice
it
alright alright ah that's different
that's different that's not right dad
no right and alright
what is that a XM what that's different
ah what do we got going on here ah what
what ha ha ha oh yes ah yes
see what you got buddy
see what you got 2600
holy crap holy crap q l1 w Bri these all
around man
one G goddamn things are getting kind of
messed up now another breezy holy hell
this is too many Bri these I'm almost at
the end guys oh my god hey why what
[Music]
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh jeez Oh
what is this hall oh oh it says again
left it's the same it's the same pattern
it's the same oh thank you guys thank
you guys so much for donating it really
does help I mean I I love doing this for
you guys as entertaining hopefully when
I get partnered which might be soon I
don't know but I don't know I've got in
trouble thinking right now I'm really
concentrating on this humming like gamer
mode right now RS a split I no problem
for me due to creep that's a corner
that's corner that's corner yes Jesus
being partnered means that you share
revenue from advertisements and whatnot
you basically get paid that's what's
important to ll one get flipped
don't look damn Brie these are
everywhere I swear
[Music]
w alright dude a creep creep creep creep
I don't think that's a corner that's not
a corner that's not a corner not a
corner not a corner not a corner not a
corner not a corner whoa what uh what
did what is this what the hell is this
what is that it's like a path under it
but what Oh what huh what Hot Diggity
lizard you panicked too much I know what
I was doing my my creep technique is
flawless no list
I'm on level I don't think this guy's
very happy at me
[Music]
p-per 8 PP 8 yes yes I know I am pissing
it off and it is great 9 WD another
split
ain't no problem for me that's the
corner that's corner and games are
pissing me off I am rocking this game
I'm all up in it
I am the bound UL nope breathe
[Music]
haha yes oh man what is that dollar sign
another breathing get out of here
get out of here I'm a man whoa don't do
that
hashtag BQ everybody tweet hashtag BQ
right now
hashtag PQ otac markiplier in there at
markiplier hashtag BQ w Z dude accrete
ow
that's not a corner not a corner no
corner and lock abouts
it is flawless it is flawless ha ha Oh
mo if you dish out their dish out the
justice yes oh god there's like a fart I
should look around see if anyone's
actually gotten this well I mean I'm
sure people have but like I can't
believe I went from barely getting 52
now I'm on the letters well don't flip
me I know your tricks
yeah I got the game in my pocket now 5r
well breathing
I hope my game doesn't like foot me when
that breed he's there cuz that would
kill me oh yeah oh yeah um I have a
Facebook page and a Twitter links are in
the description below and people just
linked it there so so thank you guys
whoa what up whoa what the hell whoa it
just blocked me in its it bugged me it
lets getting dark why wait wait nice
nice nice yeah beat it
[Music]
winner
oh yes yes yeah oh oh yeah oh yeah oh
man I did it I did it oh man I did if
you can't see that that says nice nice
oh man guys that was an incredible rush
that was just insane holy crap man no
I'm not getting out my shirt I did that
already if you want to see me with my
shirt off go to the tumblr but anyway
thank you guys so much thank you the red
death Reaper for donating so much
getting me to do this I still owe you a
flame a favor so just let me know
whatever you want anyone who donated now
let me check um see if anybody donated
let's see here $10 donation thank you so
much donated your heart thank you so
much donated $15 um see Thank You Girt
thank you Mark
thank you Karolina Phoebe thank you all
so much for helping out you guys are
amazing
amazing I can't believe it it's just
like I'm like God I won I won I won I
never thought I would win that game I'm
gonna put that up on the youtubes I'm
gonna do it sorry the livestream is
gonna end soon that was like the end so
if you don't know who I am my name is
markiplier I run the YouTube channel
markiplier game the link is in the
description below with a big youtube
button right by my Twitter and Facebook
someone's gonna post my channel soon so
thank you guys you guys are incredible
man I can't believe it I can ha
Cody donated $100 holy hell holy Hannah
that is uh that is nice too much money
oh man you guys you guys support me so
well I I can't believe it we if you
don't know if you don't know we just hit
15,000 subscribers that's what this was
two hours about you can see up at the
top we just hit 15,000 subscribers on my
channel we did it in like an
unbelievably short amount of time so
thank you guys so much without you I
would be nowhere so I'm gonna go do the
slender the new slender map I'm gonna do
it in the new slender map and we'll try
to get this all going for you but it's
because you guys are helping share my
videos and you know coming here to watch
my live streams and do all sorts of
crazy stuff like this for me so I hey I
would be nowhere without you and you
guys by sharing videos and I encourage
you to do that like the slender reaction
compilation any reaction compilation
that you like if you want to help grow
the channel please go to the one of
those reaction compilations someone can
link a reaction compilation or you can
go it's on front page of my channel if
you go there and you share it on
Facebook and Twitter it would help
immensely with getting getting the
channel where I want to be and I want to
be a hundred thousand subscribers by
June of next year and a million a year
after that so thank you guys so much so
please help out share it share the
reaction compilation because I think
those give a best idea of what I'm all
about so thanks again everybody thanks
again for sticking by thank you
everybody for joining me was the most
successful life um I've ever had so
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye bye bye
bye